.
RULE NUMBER ONE.
>> Katie: SHE WAS CERTAINLY
CAUGHT OFF GUARD AND NANCY MACE
TALKS ABOUT THAT CONTEXT,
LISTEN.
>> THERE REALLY ARE NO WORDS AND
SHE WANTED CONTEXT.
THERE IS NO CONTEXT I READ YOUR
WORD FOR WORD AND YOU ARE BEING
A HYPOCRITE COMING IN HERE
TALKING ABOUT HATE SPEECH AND
VIOLENT RHETORIC.
YOU WERE THE VERY PERSON USING
HATE SPEECH AND VIOLENT RHETORIC
TO PUT PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
DANGER.
>> Katie: THE OBVIOUS.
>> Greg: SHE REALLY SHOWED
"THEY."
YOU KNOW, I LOVE MOMENTS LIKE
THESE.
IT IS GREAT WHEN YOU WERE A KID
AND WATCHED HAPPY DAYS AND
FONZIE WOULD BEAT UP THE BULLY.
OR BIGFOOT, GREAT TV MOMENT
WHERE THE PERSON WHO DESERVES IT
AS IT COMING.
THEY ARE LIKE TERRIBLE PEOPLE AT
THESE HEARINGS.
SHE HAS NOT EVEN THE WORST.
THEY ARE THE PEOPLE THEY ARE
SAYING PARENT SHOULD NOT BE TOLD
THEIR KIDS ARE SEEKING
TRANSITION.
THIS IS A COLT.
IT IS A CULT AND ALSO, I THINK
SO, RIGHT?
ANYWAY SHE MAKES A GREAT POINT.
ATTEMPTING TO CENSOR ANYBODY BY
LANGUAGE OF INCITEMENT, IT CAN
BE USED ON ANYBODY AND ON
ANYBODY BECAUSE SO OPEN TO
INTERPRETATION OF THE WAY THIS
INFORMATION/DISINFORMATION AND
ESPECIALLY HATE SPEECH AS WE
HAVE SEEN THIS BROADEN, BROADEN,
BROADEN AND THIS ACTRESS MIGHT
LEARN FROM THIS, NO, SHE BLOCKED
NANCY MACE.
SHE WALKED HER ON TWITTER.
THAT WAS THE LESSON --
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR FROM HER
AGAIN.
SHE ALSO BLOCKED ME.
I THINK SHE BLOCKED EVERYBODY
FROM FOX.
IT JUST SHOWS SHE PREFERS TO
LIVE IN HER OWN BUBBLE.
SHE PREFERS TO LIVE HER
COGNITIVE BIAS.
SHE COMMITS THE CRIME OF SAYING
INCOME I HOPE KATIE PAVLICH GETS
ATTACKED, SHE DOESN'T SEE THAT
THE SAME WAY SOMEBODY WOULD SAY,
YOU SHOULD GET ATTACKED BECAUSE
SHE IS IN HER BUBBLE.
SHE CAN'T SEE -- SHE ONLY SEES
THE CRIME OF THE PERSON SHE
HATES IS DOING.
>> Katie: WE HEAR THE THREATS
TO DEMOCRACY OR A VERY SERIOUS
AND WHAT GOES ON ON TWITTER
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN SERIOUS.
ELON MUSK IS ALLOWING PLETHORA
OF HATE SPEECH TO THRIVE ON THE
PLATFORM AND YET, PEOPLE LIKE
THIS DO IT, THEY THINK IT IS
OKAY AND THERE WAS NO RECOURSE
FOR THEM.
>> Jessica: WE WILL SEE IF
THERE IS SOME RECOURSE.
THIS HAS GONE VIRAL AND SPEAKS
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
REPRESENTATIVES ON BOTH SIDES
LIKE NANCY MACE WHO REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS RESPECT.
THIS IS NOT A FLAME THROWING
PERSON OR SOMEONE WHO USES HER
LANGUAGE FASTLY LOOSE.
THIS IS A PERSON WHO TAKES HER
JOB SERIOUSLY.
THAT IS WHY THAT WAS SO
EFFECTIVE.
AND SHE WAS ON HER NETWORK AND
WENT ON A LIBERAL NETWORK AND
GIVING INTERVIEWS.
THINKERS OF THE OTHER PARTY.
THAT IS IMPORTANT HERE THAT IS
HOW YOU MAKE YOUR MESSAGE HEARD
SHOWING UP IN PEOPLE WHERE
PEOPLE WOULDN'T EXPECT YOU TO BE
THERE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT TOOK AWAY
FROM IT.
I THINK IT IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE I THINK IT MIRRORS
TWITTER FILES INSTALLMENT 3 OR R
IT WAS, DONALD TRUMP'S TWEET WAS
INCITING VIOLENCE AND IN HINGED
ON WHO ARE THE AMERICAN
PATRIOTS?
WHO IS HE TALKING TO?
IS HE TALKING THE GUYS WHO
STORMS A CAPITAL OR JUST TALKING
TO AMERICAN PATRIOTS AT LARGE
AND PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR HIM
SITTING AT HOME IN KENTUCKY
MINDING THEIR OWN BUSINESS?
WE HAVE TO SPEND MORE TIME
THINKING ABOUT WHAT REALLY
INCITES VIOLENCE?
IS AT ALL FLAT OUT ON THE PAGE?
IS IT HOW SOMEONE INTERPRETS IT
AND GO INTO THEM BASED ON IT?
WHAT KIND OF INTENT PUSH MARK
THAT WOMAN TESTIFYING, DOES SHE
WANT THEM TO SHOW UP AT ALL OF
THEIR HOUSES?
>> Katie: PEOPLE DID SHOW UP.
AND WANTED TO KILL SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
JESSIE, DO YOU NOT TWEET BECAUSE
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT GETTING
COLD IN FRONT OF THE CONGRESS TO
TEST ABOUT SOMETHING SOMEDAY?
>> Jesse: JOHNNY TWEETS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE SAYS, BUT I
HAVEN'T GOT IN TROUBLE SO FAR SO
HE IS DOING A GREAT JOB.
THIS IS THE LIBERAL LOGIC.
IF I CALL A TRANSSEXUAL, HE,
THEY WILL SAY, "OH, YOU'RE
CAUSING VIOLENCE."
BUT IF THE TRANSSEXUAL SAYS "A
MOB NEEDS TO GO LOOSE ON A
JUSTICE'S HOUSE.
THAT IS FREE SPEECH AND THAT IS
B.S.
THAT ARGUMENT DOESN'T GET A FAIR
SHAKE IN THE MEDIA.
SO, IF YOU SAY ANYTHING, THE
MEDIA WILL SAY, YOU'RE CAUSING
VIOLENCE AND NOT ONLY ARE YOU
CAUSING VIOLENCE, THEY ARE
CAUSING VIOLENCE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE, TO THOSE MOST
OPPRESSED.
NOBODY WANTS TO CAUSE VIOLENCE
TO ANYBODY.
YOU CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER WHAT YOU
SAID AT THAT POINT!
SO JUST ANOTHER WAY TO CENSOR
YOU.
I WILL NOT STAND FOR IT!
>> Greg: WAY TO STAND UP FOR
FREE SPEECH, JESSE!
>> Jesse: I WILL STAND UP!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Katie: YOU ARE IN A MOOD
TODAY.
>> Jessica: A LIBERAL FEDERAL
JUDGE WHOSE SON WAS GUNNED DOWN
AND HER HUSBAND WAS SHOT AS
WELL.
SO THERE IS RE